The term Mutation
brings countless fantasies to our mind.
Right from the ability to fly high in the sky,
to that of diving deep into the oceans.
We all love to have such fantastic abilities.
But these are all fictitious.
Such fantasies don't exist.
So can we say that mutation also doesn't exist?
Hold on, that's not true.
Mutation does exist.
But Mutation doesn't lead to such drastic
changes in us humans.
We can't have mutations
that give us extraordinary powers.
Rather, most mutations give rise to concern.
They result in undesirable changes from time to time.
In these upcoming videos,
we shall majorly talk about mutation,
what causes them and their types in general.
Let's begin with the definition first.
Mutation in simple words is defined as sudden and
abrupt changes to the genetic material of organisms.
Now, let's break this down to understand it better.
Sudden and abrupt changes, means a few changes
that occur suddenly and are mostly unexpected.
These changes are usually random
and disruptive to the normal functioning of the cell.
And where do these changes occur?
They occur in the genetic material of the organism.
That means in the DNA. And as a result,
either the gene or the complete chromosome
gets affected.
So mutations are spontaneous changes that
affect the DNA
or the genes or sometimes the complete chromosomes.
Now since these are the areas that get altered
mutations are categorised on the basis of them.
The two major types of mutation are genetic mutation
and Chromosomal mutation.
Let us see these types.
Let's consider this small section of the DNA.
Let's say that this part changes into another.
Another possibility is that either this base gets deleted
or an extra gets inserted.
In either case,
the outcome is that the sequence of the gene will change.
Technically, the reading frame will change.
The ribosome assembly including the tRNA
reads the genetic code in triplets.
These triplets are called codons.
Now if there's any change in a single nucleotide,
then the entire codon will change.
Thus, the reading frame will change.
And what will this result to?
That's right... the altered gene
will give rise to a different protein than the usual one.
And there are chances that this defective protein
turns out to be a harmful one.
So any change in the DNA or in the genes
can cause a shift in the reading frame.
As a result, an altered protein is produced.
This was the first type.
Now, let's zoom out of the DNA structure.
What do we see?
Yes, we see a typical chromosomal structure.
Now tell me,
what will happen if there are any alterations
in its structure?
And what if the total number of chromosomes get
altered?
Let's find the answer in the next part.
This is a representative karyotype of a human.
By now we know what a karyotype is.
Can you try to give me some conclusions of it?
You may say that it looks perfectly normal.
But let me spot a flaw for you. Do you notice this set?
This is the 21st chromosome set.
Instead of having a normal pair of chromosomes,
here, we find a triplet.
Now you may say that it may be good for the individual
as it has an extra chromosome.
But that's not the case.
Any change in the number of chromosomes
creates a lot of defects
in the normal functioning of the body.
On this note, let's understand chromosomal mutations.
As the name says,
Chromosomal mutation means
the mutation of chromosomes.
And how exactly does it get mutated?
It can happen in two ways.
One way is where the structure
of the chromosomes gets disrupted.
The other is where the number of chromosomes are
different than the usual in the organism.
Let's have a look at each type.
This is the structure of a typical chromosome.
Now imagine, this small part gets physically removed.
This would result the chromosome in getting smaller
as its segment is lost.
This also means
that if the segment had some important genes
then they will also get lost which can result in severe abnormalities.
Such type of a mutation is called deletion.
This is where the part of the chromosome gets deleted.
Now imagine, this part of the chromosome gets duplicated.
As a result , the chromosome's length increases.
Needless to say, this will also result in some of the other abnormality in the individual.
This type of mutation is called duplication.
Now comes the next type.
These are two different gene segments.
Imagine they get flipped. Thus the chromosome will appear like this.
This is called inversion.
Do you think this type of mutation is harmful?
It may or may not be harmful
depending on which genes get flipped.
Now, let's take one more chromosome.
Imagine a part of this chromosome gets removed
and gets inserted in this chromosome.
What will be the result?
That's correct.
Both the chromosomes will change drastically.
This type of mutation is called as insertion.
And now comes the last type.
Instead of a segment getting
inserted to another chromosome,
let's imagine a situation,
where a segment from each chromosome
gets interexchanged.
So this segment will get into this chromosome
and vice versa.
This kind of mutation also results in abnormalities
as both the chromosomes get altered completely.
Any idea what this type will be named as?
Well, this type of mutation is called translocation.
All these mutations
resulting in the disruption of
normal chromosomal structures
are broadly capped under a single heading.
They are categorised as chromosomal aberrations.
Now this was about the mutations that involve
changes in the structure of the chromosomes.
What about the mutations that involve
a change in the number of chromosomes?
Let's understand that in the next part.
This is a normal chromosome,
while this is a disrupted one.
When the structure of a chromosome gets altered,
it's called chromosomal aberration.
We have seen this.
Now, let's move on to the second type.
It's the mutation that involves
a change in the number of chromosomes.
It's called as a Aneuploidy.
In literal terms a Aneuploidy means,
the presence of an abnormal number of chromosomes
in a cell.
So the carrier type of a person with trisomy 21
is an example of Aneuploidy.
The presence of
one additional chromosome in the 21st set
gives rise to a total of 47 chromosomes in a person.
So instead of a normal 46 chromosomes
this person has an additional chromosome.
To be precise an additional autosome.
This case of a Aneuploidy is called trisomy 21.
This is because
there are three chromosomes
instead of two in the 21st set.
The problem of Trisomy 21
leads to a condition called Down syndrome.
We will get into the details of these disorders
in our higher grades.
But for now,
let's focus on understanding the
chromosomal mutations.
This Aneuploidy involved an autosome.
Now tell me,
what if the number of sex chromosome alters?
So instead of XY what if an individual has XXY?
Is that even possible in the first place?
Well yes,
there can be individuals with an
additional X chromosome.
This condition is called Klinefelter syndrome.
Such individuals exhibit both
masculine as well as feminine characteristics.
Now in the case of females, imagine that
instead of addition
there is a deletion of an X chromosome.
This would mean XO.
So this individual will have only one X chromosome.
This condition is called Turner syndrome.
There are a few developmental abnormalities
in such scenarios.
These individuals have a total of 45 chromosomes only.
These were a few examples of Aneuploidy that involves
autosomes and sex chromosomes.
Now before we conclude, tell me one thing.
What causes these mutations?
How can DNA or genes or
entire chromosomes get altered?
There are several factors named mutagens
which lead to alterations.
Some of them include radiation,
chemicals and even certain consumable items.
To summarize, we have two major types of mutations.
One which involves alterations in the DNA or the genes.
These mutations result a shift in the reading frame
resulting in defective protein synthesis.
Alterations in the structure results in
chromosomal aberrations.
They can be categorised as deletion,
duplication, inversion, insertion and translocation.
The other is where
the number of chromosomes are different
than the usual in the organism.
It's called Aneuploidy.
The changes can be in the autosomes
as well as the sex chromosomes.
Here, the total number of chromosomes in a cell
are different from the usual.
This was about mutations in general.
To find more interesting videos
Do not forget to subscribe to our channel.